I think the comparison between Tyrion
Lannister and Richard 30 is a very good
one a 16th century historians describe
Richard the third
you know as this hunchbacked
evil-looking character whose physical
unpleasantness directly reflected his
lack of moral character Richard the
thirds been fight through history
especially in Shakespeare as being
monstrously deformed and you could
characterize Richard the third
as quote/unquote a [ __ ] that's how a
lot of people see Tyrion Lannister in
the world of Westeros but of course as
the viewer we know that's not the whole
story
Tyrion the IMP of House Lannister he
killed your father he murdered the hand
of the king oh did I kill him too I
loved Richard the third he's one of my
favorite historical characters he wasn't
a hunchback he didn't have a twisted arm
but because he was the king who was
deposed by Henry a seventh so the Tudor
historians tried to make him a
physically twisted deceitful kin slaying
child slaying monster and a lot of what
happened to Richard the third is
happening to Tyrion I wish I was the
monster you think I am Tyrion someone
who's easily cast as a villain
the dwarf hated by the gods so they
twist his body into unfortunate shapes
this is a clear sign of the evil inside
him this was like how the medieval
mindset worked I did not kill Joffrey
but I wish that I had
[Applause]
bring me his head that Starks a very
interesting character I mean obviously
the patriarch of the House of Stark
which if we're looking for Wars the
Roses parallels is like the House of
York but if you look at Richard Duke of
York the real historical patriarch his
career really doesn't map on to Ned's
journey very well and actually there's
another character who I think is much
more comparable with Ned Stark and
that's William Lord Hastings now
Hastings was the great pal of Edward the
fourth who I think unquestionably is
Robert Baratheon and they had this very
close
chummy personal relationship and we can
all remember you know the early episodes
of season one where we see Robert
Baratheon and Ned Stark enjoying that
kind of fraternal relationship well
that's Hastings Ned with the fourth all
over and what's really interesting is
Hastings helped rich the third to take
the throne well it were the fourth dies
but afterwards
Richard turned on him and he was
summarily beheaded and I think there's a
lot of the career of Hastings that you
can follow through the story of Ned
Stark
you know this loyal friend of the king
who out lives the King tries to do the
right thing and what is a reward head
rolling in the dirt
in the name of Robert of the house
Baratheon the first of his name don't
look away king of the Andals in the
first father will know if you do I
entered the house dark
sentence you to die beheading for
aristocrats started really as a decent
way to get rid of an aristocrat you'd
rather be beheaded go to the theory then
be hanged kneel my lord and so it became
in the real Wars of the Roses sort of
the the go-to method of dispatching your
enemies beheadings for noble people were
very common the biggest crime is treason
so what Ned Stark does for example
that's going to bring punishment that is
fatal so long as I'm your king treason
shall never go unpunished
so Ilyn bring me his head glad to see
you're protecting the throne a sturdy
old thing how many kings asses have
polished it I wonder the iron throne
already the concept of the iron throne
in the world of Westeros represents
ultimate power and that's pretty much
how it was in medieval England as well
we're talking about actually a marble
chair whoever was sitting on that marble
chair wearing the crown of England
wielded ultimate power in the country I
command the council to make all
necessary arrangements for my coronation
I wish to be crowned within the
fortnight we had during the wars the
Roses was an enormous series of
factional battles between different
families all trying to take that crown
take that throne and take power for
themselves when you play the game of
Thrones you win or you die there is no
middle ground I'm not sure exactly where
George got the concept of a--they of
what has been called the least
comfortable chair in the entire kingdom
but a single power was really the
definition of all medieval rulership one
person ruled so when we get a
transformation in power when this
happens anywhere in Europe but
especially in England there's going to
be every
buddy fighting for one side another I
did warn you not to trust me there will
be sides taken there will be blows and
there will be rebellions